hey youtubers is Charlie so yesterday in
my core video I asked you all to submit
questions so I picked a bunch of up so
we could follow up on all the really big
stuff lots of Zaheer airbending disciple
talk so it's all very interesting real
quick shout out to Oh master and ninja
DC you guys are the winners from last
night's giveaway I'll be reaching out to
you on your channels for details but the
next round of the giveaway will start
whenever I post next week's you know
double episode video for anyone who's
brand new to my channel all you do to
participate in those is be a subscriber
and leave a comment if you guys ever
wondered why the giveaways are tied to
comments it's just because those are the
things that I value most like if you
wanted to help me the most all you have
to do is just leave a comment is
basically how I learn what you guys are
thinking it's basically where the
YouTube community lives and that's the
thing I care about the most so that's
why it's all about comments speaking of
comments let's answer some questions so
careful for spoilers from last night's
episodes if you haven't seen them yet
I'll wait just a second okay ready let's
go question number one
Lucas asks will we see a civil war with
the earth Kingdom like the people
against the Queen so usually in all
seasons of Korra there's like a couple
types of conflicts there's like cores
main spiritual conflict and then there's
like some sort of you know human versus
human conflict so I'm expecting core to
battle team Zaheer and that'll be like
one of the plots and then they'll have
some sort of you know human on human
violence based on what we've seen so far
I don't think anyone besides the earth
Queen is going to be the villain of that
human conflict like that human on human
one so yes you know earth Queen versus
our people I don't know if it's just
gonna turn out to be a straight-up civil
war but no one will be killing anyone
that's not really what core is about and
it wouldn't really fit with the
airbending philosophy that all life is
sacred
she's been subjugating all over people
not just the airbenders but I think it
would be a nice resolution if those you
know northern air temple airbenders from
the earth Kingdom came back and made her
see the error of her ways and resolved
the conflict that way the earth Queen is
a lot like the Queen of Hearts from
Alice in Wonderland you know really
over-the-top and comical but I think
there are a couple ways her plot could
resolve itself so one way would be for
Korra and those other airbenders to
teach her the error of their ways and
she just becomes a better person the
other way would be for her to kind of
get pushed aside and most of her power
given to like a new parliament or
something like that that's kind of what
happened in the UK although it was
voluntary
the monarchy still exists but
over the last hundred years or so the
royal family has slowly given more and
more of their decision-making power to
the government and you get to a
situation today where the monarchy
becomes more figureheads and the
parliament does like the day-to-day job
of making sure species four five six
does not obliterate the human race
shout out to Torchwood fans push number
two Camille asks what's so important
about Korra that team Zaheer couldn't do
what they want to do with egg whenever
he was still alive so good question core
is about 19 right now so let's assume
they got thrown in prison about 19 years
ago they look like they're about the
same age as Tenzin so they'd have to be
in their early 30s whenever they were
arrested I can think of two big reasons
why they'd go for Korra versus Aang
especially at that time the first big
reason being that Aang was kind of on
his way out like he was dying whenever
they were just forming their plan like
aim was in his final years and either
wouldn't have enough strength to do
whatever see here one of the Avatar to
do or if they're trying to convince the
avatar to help them anguish just to
stuck in his ways and would have never
agreed to their mystery plan whatever it
is I really think it's more of a
combination of those two things you know
Aang was on his way out and was
basically getting ready to die and they
didn't think that he would help them so
whenever they saw Korra coming along
they just thought you know hate will
raise her and then whenever it comes
time to do whatever it is we want to do
she'll believe us we'll be her friends
so she'll help us that's kind of a twist
on what unlock wanted except he wanted
to kill raava I don't think that's what
see here wants there's really still too
much that we don't know about him or his
plan to start making guesses so I'm just
gonna call it Z here's mystery plan
until he does his evil guy monologue and
explains everything
question number three wargaming asks
where did Sukkos dragon come from so in
the dragon days comic Eng saves the last
dragon egg so it either came from that
it hatched from that or it came from the
Dragons in last airbender remember we
learned that Iroh had protected ran and
shot the last two dragons we actually
just learned in this past week in the
video game that nickelodeon posted the
Zuko game that Zuko's dragons name is
drunk he was born around 18 years ago
meaning he is the same age as Korra
pretty much it's funny to think that the
birth of Zuko's dragon and the birth of
the new avatar connected but I can see
why they would want to connect those two
big major events I'm sure there are
actually a lot of big things that were
connected to course birth including the
here's mystery plot
I think the big takeaway about Duke owes
dragon though is is that he's the child
of those two dragons from Last Airbender
or he came from an egg that survives
sozin's destruction whatever sozin set
everyone to just start hunting dragons
down I've always thought the dragon eggs
take forever to hatch so it's possible
it could be from sozin's time just
because in all the different fantasy
series I've ever seen dragons are
extremely long-lived and for the most
part there's usually a correlation
between the length of a creatures life
and the time it takes for de Geste date
and be born or hatched question number
four Benjamin asks do you think that
Aang is the one that taught stew here
airbending yes I definitely think that's
possible I saw a lot of you guys
speculating that he could have been like
an early airbending disciple and at some
point and could have taken his bending
away with energy bending so it's
possible that Zaheer tried to enact some
sort of plot when Aang was still alive
then took his powers away then Zaheer
tried again whenever Korra was born was
thrown in prison so technically in book
three this is his third try to do
whatever it is he wants to do and since
he's an airbender again it's possible
that harmonic convergence just restored
his bending it would explain why he's so
good and there wouldn't have been many
other people other than Aang that is who
could have taught him about airbending
about 30 or 40 years ago so I definitely
think that he was someone's disciple the
only other person I could think of would
be like a random guru that we just
haven't met yet or we didn't know about
question number five Andre asks do you
think that opal is actually Lin's
daughter no I don't really think it's
gonna get too complicated with the
beifong story I think that the whole Lin
suyin backstory is going to be a simple
take on their big differences like
beifong trying to be super responsible
and strict and soohyun being rebellious
and getting away with everything if you
remember sue and said that Toph wasn't
really super happy with the way either
Lin or suyun turned out I'm assuming
that Lando is probably just bitter about
soo-eun ever being held to account for
her actions
full disclosure though I have not seen
like the leaked episode 6 so I know
there's a beifong flashback I just I
don't know how it goes down
my explanation just kind of makes Lyn
seemed more like an emotional child in
that she can't just get over the fact
that they see the world differently I do
think we're meant to draw a few
similarities between the ridiculousness
of the earth Queen and Lin like they're
both really stubborn people stuck in
their way
obviously I'm expecting Linda turn that
around I mean she is a good person
question number six Kevin asks do you
think that the real antagonists are the
White Lotus not really I do think that
the real antagonist is actually
ignorance I think I mean it's kind of a
silly explanation but I think that's
what it is like all the characters just
have to get used to change and that's
the real obstacle to overcome so here it
just seems like a villain right now
because his plan takes him in opposition
of team avatar and I haven't seen any
evidence that season the White Lotus has
done anything Shady like they've really
only been following Zuko's orders it
sounds silly but they all apply just get
to the point this season where like some
really big change will come and everyone
in the world will just have to learn to
deal that kind of already did happen
with harmonic convergence but see here
could just be trying to bind the
physical in the spirit realms in a much
more profound way the spirit Korra
almost hidden Republic City in that
first episode said that we're all the
same even the avatar should know that
that sounded really ominous to me like
somehow this season everyone will become
one in a much more obvious way question
number 7 Siobhan asks is it just me or
is the Dai Li in the White Lotus getting
way less badass it seems like they're
just trying to make the new characters
like Kai and team Zaheer seem even more
badass so they make the other characters
seem weaker they're more of a threat if
they can take down Zuko the White Lotus
and the Dai Li and since we haven't
really had like a big earth-shaking
conflict since the hundred year war an
egg's time it's possible that people
could have just gotten soft since then
so the Dai Li and the White Lotus could
both be more like maintenance level
benders not the kind of superhero epic
benders you see emerge during times of
war hopefully we get some more details
in the next couple of episodes about
what's going on in the world right now
so then that might kind of explain why
team Zaheer is so much of a badass
question number 8 Danny Phantom asks do
you think that say here's void has
something to do with the original
airbenders no not necessarily I do think
it has something to do with energy
bending and transcending physical
existence though I know I mentioned
conquering death in my last video but
the best way to do that would be to
exist as pure energy that might not be
what see here's trying to do exactly but
I don't think he's just trying to
contact someone I think it's possible
that he could be trying to energy Bend
everyone like in a much bigger way like
whenever you see Korra and Aang go into
the astral state or some twist on that
so guru Pathik chakra
might be making a comeback question
number nine I love me asks why did Nick
take all the episodes down off Nick comm
probably because they're just trying to
increase librarians for Korra on
Nickelodeon on television I don't think
it'll work and I don't think that their
strategy of not putting episodes on
iTunes quickly is going to work either
right now the only way to watch the show
legally is to watch it on Nickelodeon
but if you live in a country where Nick
isn't available which is most places it
really hurts their viewership it's a
whole big thing but my sympathies go out
to you if you do not get Nickelodeon
wherever you live I can't allow any
streaming leaks in the comments here
just because they're illegal but that's
typically the only way to find new Korra
episodes it sucks but there's currently
no legal streaming options available
question number ten and last one so
commenter Scott pointed out some of the
really amazing voice talent this season
and since I haven't done a video just
about the voice actors I wanted to read
his comment so here are some of the
really awesome avatar Legend of Korra
Last Airbender characters that you may
have already recognized there's Jack
decenas Sokka on last airbender he
doesn't have any Korra credits on IMDB
right now but Ava Marie Saint is old
Katara on Korra JK Simmons everyone
knows as shirtless Tenzin Mindy sterling
as cheap crankypants Lin beifong DB
sweeney as old egg on Korra
and hey she is the new suyin beifong
character Lisa Edelstein you probably
remember from last season as kaya she's
also on this season dante basco as young
Zuko on last airbender and Zuko's
grandson Iroh on Korra then we have Mark
Hamill as Fire Lord Ozai Grady Lyle as
young as Ulla and now as the armless
waterbender pylean Korra which is really
cool and then there's Henry Rollins
playing the new main characters here
Nickelodeon for some reason hasn't done
any big casting announcements for book
three voice actors but there's some
really nice additions and I'm really
happy with the new voice actors
especially Henry Rollins is just so
awesome so next week there will be two
more episodes again episode 6 and 7 I
think they're going to resolve the
metalbending city story and then move on
to something new in episode 7 since
those 2 episodes will basically comprise
the halfway point of the episodes I'm
hoping we learn a little bit more about
what's a here's plan is I know everyone
really wants to know where Toph is but
I'm not expecting to learn that anytime
soon I have seen some really cool
theories on the red
as a possible alternative antagonist as
it relates to the pipe show game you
know the white lotus tiles I don't have
lots of information about that so if
something develops I'll definitely
include that in a future video so right
now click here to get my review of the
episodes and click here to learn about
my top 10 Last Airbender characters
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives